all right so here's what I'm going to
ask us to do now I'm going to think
about uh two applications of this one of
them is going to be quite quick please
don't bother trying to write it down and
keep up I'll just give you the notes um
after this but the last one or the
second one I will ask you to ride along
with me okay
so do you guys remember encountering
questions like this is this ring a bell
um we call this an inclined plane which
is a fancy way of saying um you're not
level it's not horizontal you're like
pushing a you know something up a hill
right so you you've probably seen these
before and they come up a lot in physics
right so you've got this Mass here
Gravity is acting on it towards well
downward for us but towards the center
of the earth and then you usually have
either
um you know maybe you've got a a wire
that's pulling up so it's a tension
force or you might have say they might
say there's a there's an engine and it's
a car and it's it's trying to go uphill
right and so that's the thing that's
providing force in the upward Direction
and then you also have a normal force
where does that come from by the way
that normal force
very good so um normal in this context
means at right angles I guess now that
we're in 3D World we would say
orthogonal to the surface that you're
sitting upon right and so it's got that
um facing upwards now what would we
normally do what's the normal approach
right well in order to work out anything
with this situation I mean I haven't
given you a question in this case
um but you guys know that basically what
you have to do is you would put you
would superimpose like an X Y plane onto
this um situation so it's horizontal and
vertical and then you would say well the
normal force is off at a widow angle and
the tension force is off at some weirdo
angle so you have to work out which part
of the normal force and which part of
the tension force go in the directions
that you're interested in the x's and
the Y's right so we call this um you
guys have seen it before right resolving
vectors so you would get a diagram
something like this
so you can see
um there's the the object I've just
simplified it down to a point normal
force going in the way that I said
tension force going in the way that I
said um but then really what you want to
do is you don't want this tension force
being off in some weirdo spot you just
say look we can simplify this and say
they're all acting on a single the
center of mass right so that's why that
that dot really represents the center of
the object there's your forces going up
there's your gravity going down and then
you've got this tug in and um uh this
tug of war between the normal attention
Force Parts in the horizontal directions
okay
now this is fine you guys have done this
before it works great but when you've
got projection
um in your uh what's the weather looking
for in your box of tools right in the
set of strategies you've got another way
to do this right let me just go right
back to the start here
when we go and have a look here can you
see that when when we say what's the
length of the shadow of one vector upon
another effectively what you're doing is
you're resolving what part of vector a
is facing in the direction of vector B
and in this case I've drawn B to be
horizontal but B doesn't have to be
horizontal right like isn't there what I
could do is I could say forget about
this being a shadow now so I'm going to
get rid of the sun right I could say hey
there's
um you know bees facing off in some
weird Direction
this still works out doing the vector
projection still works out how much of
vector a is heading in the direction of
vector B so we've just chosen instead of
an X Y plane I've now got a I don't know
a something else B plan right I guess
you know put put some random orthogonal
axis in here that's one of them and then
B's the other one okay
so this is the reason why it's hard to
I'm not asking you to draw this and keep
up but what I'm going to do here a
secondary method and you can compare
this in the notes later is to say I'm
not going to resolve along the X Y plane
horizontal vertical I'm just going to do
it in relation to the incline now I want
you to think look at this question you
tell me why actually it's quite sensible
to choose the incline as my
quote-unquote horizontal axis why is the
incline here this why is it a better
choice than X and Y the like normal
until up to the surface so if you were
to thank your surface be like I guess
uh one point or whatever you want to
call it that you're working with like a
nice you know a triangle yeah very very
good that's um that's I think the best
way to say it because you've already got
two things that are orthogonal to each
other so if they're orthogonal why not
make that your your quote-unquote X and
Y axis right
um you know what this is similar to it's
like when um have you have you guys done
questions yet around
um when you drop like an object off a
cliff or out of a plane have you
encountered those questions yet
yeah yep so you guys know
um we can set the origin to be wherever
we like right and I guess a normal place
to put the origin might be say the
ground if you are throwing an object and
it goes up and then it comes down but if
you are like from a plane or from a
cliff maybe it makes sense to call the
plane or the top of the cliff you call
that the origin right so you're like I
can make the origin wherever I want and
in the same way I can make my axes
wherever I want it's just whatever's
convenient to me whatever makes my
calculations easier right so here's what
it's going to look like
I will take this same situation the
incline plane and then all I'm going to
do is I guess if you want you could
twist your head but on my diagram here
I'm actually oh there we go I'm just
going to rotate the situation
um if you want to think about it this
way I've got a new frame of reference
right and oh I didn't get it quite right
let me try and make that a little oh
that'll just have to do okay there you
go use your imagination so now what I've
got is the plane is what I view as the
horizontal and so you see the normal and
the tension force there I don't need to
do any resolution they're already
resolved it's just the gravity it's just
the weight force that needs to be
resolved and that's resolving one vector
rather than two so you end up with a
situation like this and it's just half
the amount of work so you just Define
your I and J unit vectors in the
directions of your normal and your
tension force and then off you go okay
so that was the first application I
asked you not to write that one here's
the second one this is where we're going
to finish I think we've just got enough
time so make a little heading for me
which is
um perpendicular distance
now when we say perpendicular distance
this is our shorthand for saying
what is the um what's the minimum or
what's the shortest distance between a
point and a vector so maybe I should
just write that down as like our our
subtitle right this is the the shortest
or the minimum distance
between
a point and a vector
now the reason why we call this
perpendicular distance right is because
you don't need to draw this part if I
had just two points right here's a or no
sorry let's call it P shall we
um here's P here's Q right the distance
between those two is unambiguous right
you're like well I just work out using
Pythagoras right and then off you go
okay but if I said instead of Point Q if
I had some kind of vector like so
let's put whoops I'll make it lower case
right let's have a Q over here there's
lots of different points I can sorry
lots of different distances that I could
say I could say this is the distance or
this is the distance or this is the
distance and they're all going towards
Vector Q right so the perpendicular
distance if I draw this here and put it
at right angles make it orthogonal
um that's the shortest way to get there
okay so here's what we're going to do
I'd like you please to draw some
arbitrary p
and then let's Place some Vector a
somewhere in space okay so maybe I'll
put it somewhere like here
okay so what I want is the um distance
the perpendicular distance the shortest
distance from P to a now there's a
weirdness here which um I don't know how
else to explain but to say even though
like you might say oh
um a starts and finishes at this spot
here and here right so is the shortest
distance the minimum distance is it
actually this which is not perpendicular
and for some reason like I guess the way
we think about it is a could be anywhere
along this infinite line and we just
want to get the shortest point to where
a could be okay so in fact what we're
going to add on to here is a sort of
stretching off to infinite infinity
version of a and we're still going to
work out
um the the right angle distance okay
so what we're going to try and determine
is this distance here
okay so if we put this at right angles
this is the distance I want so let's
call that D for distance
but in order to do some actual like
calculations I'm going to have to put
more onto this diagram so sorry it's
going to get a little bit busy I hope
you've drawn your diagram reasonably
large let's call that distance there
let's call it the distance from P to
some other point Q okay so another way I
could write this is I could say it's the
magnitude of PQ you'll see in a minute
why I'm adding another point there and
referring to them okay now the second
thing I'm going to do is do you guys
remember the difference between a
displacement vector and a position
Vector what's the um what's the
difference between those
okay fantastic a position Vector starts
from the origin so that's why we could
say oh it's like
um where is it relative to o i i don't
start from some arbitrary place if I
start from the origin then I just have
the length right so what I'm going to do
is at the moment I've just drawn a
floating around in FL in free space okay
but what I'm going to do is this
perpendicular distance doesn't depend on
where a is it just depends on how p and
a are related to each other so to
simplify my calculations and my working
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
imagine picking up P picking up a and
I'm going to move them so that it's not
a displacement in Vector anymore it's a
position Vector so let us put the tail
of a On the Origin okay
so now I've got an o
that Vector little a it's from o to a
spot capital A so I guess there's a
there's a point on the end there
and then relative to
um my position P right I guess you would
say that I'm going to go from the origin
over to my point P I guess we would
normally describe that as Little P okay
all right now I wonder if your brain is
ticking and you're seeing where I can
use projection and therefore the dot
product in here okay to work out this
distance from P to Q
P to Q
yeah I'm I'm gonna have to project
there's a couple different ways I could
do this right I could project op
onto uh onto this PQ right or I could
project uh this P Vector onto this oq or
the a vector right either of them would
work okay now the question is which of
those is easier to work out I'm going to
suggest the second one because I can
know what p is if I know the coordinates
of B capital P and I already have a
defined for me if it's if it's a vector
right so I think those two are going to
be easier to work with so I'm going to
project P onto a okay
what that will do is it will relate it
will give me the length of this Shadow
here and then I can use that to work out
the the distance of D I can use that
with Pythagoras or as I'm about to show
you I can actually do that in an even
more direct way okay so now let's start
the proof okay do you guys agree
that the vector p q
which I've got there in blue right
a way that I can get that from my
original two vectors is I can say let's
go from P to O like so
and then I can go from o up to Q do you
agree that doing Po and then oq is the
same as doing PQ yeah so I've done that
in purple so let's let's just write that
down that's p o
plus o q
okay now what what are these two things
right well you can see what's the
relationship between Po and the vector
Little P what's the relationship there
negative yeah because it's going in the
opposite direction so it's actually
negative Little P okay so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to say let's replace
that it's negative p
um what about oq well this is that
shadow idea before right can you picture
op like I'm going to put the sun over
here right here's the Sun
it's shining down at um op onto oq so it
gives us this length over here okay but
that's just the the scalar projection if
I do that length so if I actually do the
vector projection which is the notation
you saw before that is the projection of
P onto a
does that make sense
and then lastly remember we're trying to
work out what PQ is but when I when I
actually do the magnitude of it that's
just going to be equal to d right so
what I'm going to do is maybe just look
up for a brief moment just so you don't
miss it okay what I'm going to do now is
I'm going to apply a magnitude to
everything like so okay so what that
gives me on the left hand side is the
perpendicular distance that I was
wanting
and then on the right hand side I'm just
going to write the um the projection
first because then I have a minus in the
middle so it's the projection of P onto
a
take away
that Vector p and that's it that is the
formula for perpendicular distance using
the projection and obviously the
projection uses the dot product which is
the whole point of today okay
so
um
I I went a bit longer than I intended
sorry about that uh and I know I've done
a lot of theory today and your brain is
probably a bit whoa okay I I hope you
were able to follow it I hope I was able
to explain from Line to Line so it isn't
just like why is that there I don't know
like why did we why did we have so many
bees in this formula I don't know they
just appeared okay I hope I Justified it
for you sufficiently